>> Katie: IT'S A BLUE STATE
SPENDING SPREE, COURTESY OF YOU,
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
PRESIDENT BIDEN BAILING OUT
STATES WITH $350 BILLION.
MANY DON'T NEED IT.
FOR EXAMPLE, LIBERAL CALIFORNIA
JUST ANNOUNCED A $75 BILLION
BUDGET SURPLUS.
BUT IT'S STILL GETTING
$27 BILLION FROM BIDEN, U.
GOVERNOR GAVIN KNUTSON IS NOW
SENDING STIMULUS CHECKS TO
TWO-THIRDS OF THE RESIDENTS IN
HIS STATE.
BILL de BLASIO IS BEING
ACCUSED OF SPENDING BILLIONS IN
COVID CASH, LIKE A DRUNKEN
SAILOR.
SO JUST SAY, WE FOUND A GOOD
THING ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
GETTING A CHECK.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
YEAH, I MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE OUT
THERE.
I COULD SURE USE THE MONEY WITH
THESE HIGH GAS PRICES.
LET ME TELL YOU.
IT IS FUNNY TO LOOK AT THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS WHO ARE OUT
THERE MANAGING LAND AND
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE AND
OPENING UP SCHOOLS AND TRYING TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET.
AND THEN YOU HAVE COME OF THE
MEDIA JUST CALLED HIM RACIST.
AND THEN YOU HAVE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS.
ALL THEY DO IS SPEND AND THEY
SAY THEY CARE.
AND THAT'S ALL THEY DO.
SURPLUS SPEND.
DEFICIT, SPEND.
RECESSION, SPEND.
WE ARE IN A BOOM, SPEND.
HEY, IF THERE'S A PROBLEM ON THE
BORDER, YOU SPEND IN GUATEMALA.
I WISH I COULD BE REINCARNATED
AS A DEMOCRAT.
SO EASY.
JUST SPEND AND ANYBODY THAT
DISAGREES, YOU ARE A RACIST.
>> Katie: DANA, THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT REPUBLICANS WERE
WORRIED ABOUT.
THIS IS WHY THEY VOTED AGAINST
THE COVID RELIEF PACKAGE BECAUSE
IT'S A BIG WASTE OF MONEY GOING
TO DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: THIS IS THE OTHER
THING ABOUT THE GAVIN NEWSOM
PIECE.
HE ANNOUNCED THAT HE IS GOING TO
SEND AN ADDITIONAL STIMULUS
CHECKED EVERYBODY RIGHT BEFORE
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN ELECTION.
AND IF YOU REMEMBER, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND I ALSO
DISAGREE WITH US.
HE WANTED TO PUT OUT THE
STIMULUS CHECKS RIGHT AWAY,
RIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION
APPEARED HE WANTED HIS NAME OUT
THEM IN A LETTER TO GO TO EVERY
AMERICAN.
THE DEMOCRATS CRIED FOUL.
ANOTHER POINT ON THIS, WHEN THEY
PASSED THE COVID RELIEF WITH THE
MONEY ON IT, THEY SAID, THE
DEMOCRAT SAID THAT STATES COULD
NOT USE ANY OF THAT MONEY TO GO
TOWARDS TAX RELIEF FOR THEIR
CITIZENS.
NOW, 13 ATTORNEY GENERALS ARE
SUING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SAYING YOU CAN'T TELL US WE CAN
AND CAN'T DO IN TERMS OF TAX IN
OUR OWN PEOPLE.
BUT IF YOU, APPARENTLY YOU CAN'T
GIVE IT BACK IN THE FORM OF TAX
RELIEF, BUT YOU CAN GIVE OUT
STIMULUS CHECKS?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> Katie: YEAH.
GREG, MAY BE BILL de BLASIO
CAN USE SOME OF THAT MONEY TO
CLEAN UP YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD AFTER
IT SALUTED.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
I THINK I GOT A GOOD MODEL.
BILLS BRIBE BETTER.
THIS IS WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
IT'S BRIBING PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHATEVER BUT HE IS DOING.
DON'T INSULT DRUNKEN SAILORS BY
COMPARING THEM TO BILL
DE BLASIO.
>> Katie: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: OKAY, THIS IS WHY
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU GO OUTSIDE TO THE
BOARDWALK THAT YOU USE TO ENJOY
MAYBE A DECADE AGO, THEY ARE
SWAMPED WITH DERELICTS.
SOME ARE VERY VIOLENT.
SOME ARE MENTALLY ILL.
SOME ARE FRESHLY RELEASED.
THEY ARE COMINGLING WITH OTHERS
AND COMMITTING CRIMES, INCLUDING
HATE CRIMES AGAINST ASIANS.
YET IN CALIFORNIA COME YOU GET A
SURPLUS.
THEY COULD SOLVE EVERYTHING WITH
THAT MONEY IF THEY WANTED TO BUT
FOR SOME REASON THEY DON'T.
THIS IS A REALLY INTERESTING
THING THAT'S GOING ON.
IT'S INFURIATING TO SOMEONE LIKE
ME WHO LIVES THERE.
BUT IN NEW YORK CITY, YOU HAVE A
MALE ROLE RACE IN WHICH THE
LEFT-WING CANDIDATES ARE RUNNING
ON A GET TOUGH PLATFORM.
SO WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU?
THE WRITING IS ON THE WALL AND
IT'S IN BLOOD.
AND THEY REALIZE THAT IT'S NOT
GETTING BETTER AND AS THE SUMMER
GETS HOTTER, THEY ARE COUNTING
ON MORE VIOLENCE.
JUST LIKE WHAT WE SAW IN TIME
SQUARE TWO DAYS AGO WHEN A CHILD
WAS INJURED.
PEOPLE WERE SHOT IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT AT TIMES SQUARE BUT WE
COULDN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
IT'S LEFT-WING POLICIES THAT ARE
DESTROYING THE CITIES AND PEOPLE
KEEP REELECTING THEM.
>> Katie: THEY DO.
JUAN, WHY DO THEY KEEP DOING
THAT?
>> Juan: LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
THERE WAS NEVER ANYBODY SHOT IN
TIMES SQUARE UNDER REPUBLICAN?
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT, FINE.
>> Greg: REMEMBER RUDY
GIULIANI?
THAT IS THE DUMBEST COMMENT.
>> Juan: YOU HAD YOUR TURN.
THAT'S SO SILLY.
>> Greg: IT IS SILLY.
IT IS SILLY.
>> Juan: SO HERE'S THE THING.
HERE'S THE THING.
>> Greg: IT IS THE GREATEST
TOURIST ATTRACTION IN THE WORLD.
DID YOU REMEMBER THAT?
IS THAT NOT TRUE?
>> Juan: IT'S NOT TRUE.
NOT TRUE.
WHAT WE HAD WAS A REVIVAL OF
NEW YORK.
YOU KNOW, YOU TALK ABOUT CRIME.
YOU KNOW --
LETS GO BACK.
I WILL GO BACK TO THE STIMULUS.
A MUCH MORE INTERESTED IN THAT.
I AM TAKEN BY THE IDEA THAT YOU
SEE REPUBLICANS OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW CAMPAIGNING, GOING HOME TO
TOWN HALL MEETINGS AND TAKING
CREDIT AS IF THEY HAD VOTED FOR
THIS PACKAGE.
AND YOU SAY, WELL WAIT A SECOND,
REPUBLICANS DIDN'T VOTE FOR IT.
BUT THEY WANT TO TAKE CREDIT FOR
IT NOW.
AND THE THING ABOUT THIS IS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE CRITICISM EITHER
OF STIMULUS OR ON EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS, AND THAT'S THE BIG
ARGUMENT RIGHT NOW.
WHY DO WE HAVE ENHANCED
UNEMPLOYMENT?
IS IT DRIVING DOWN THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WILLING TO GO BACK TO
WORK?
IT JUST STRIKES ME AS ALMOST
INSULTING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND SAYING SOMEHOW WE DON'T WANT
TO WORK?
THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT JOBS?
PEOPLE I MEET ALL WANT TO WORK
AND ALL WANT BETTER JOBS.
AND I JUST, YOU KNOW, IT OFTEN
TIMES GETS INTO ANTI-IMMIGRANT
STUFF.
WHY IS THE NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR
SPENDING MONEY ON UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
REMEMBER, THESE ARE THE
JANITORS.
THESE ARE THE TRUCK DRIVERS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DELIVERED ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
US.
THEY ARE OUR NEIGHBORS.